si
[Musik]
wir haben das terminal verlassen und
sind hier wieder raus um gegenseite ja
eigentlich keinerlei infos mir selber
gucken wir zurechtkommen
das was ich weiß weiß sie aus
persönlichen gesprächen mit zollbeamten
polizisten und diesen park anweisen
wobei die informationssicherheit
durchaus auch widersprochen habe wir
sind kurz bei 1 angekommen findet
zwischenlandung um nach 90 fliegen weil
wir in brüssel
kennst du das flugzeug hatte und man
statt einzusteigen am flugzeug musste
mal aus dagegen von der nun stellen wir
hier ohne informationen
wahrscheinlich müssen wir uns morgen
fliegen oder übermorgen oder so suchen
sie ein hotel oder so oder wir pendler
am flughafen mal schauen